[Applause]
here's Marie he's got 27 points
slaughter from him is on target he's got
29 tremendous real fat double-teamed and
turns it over excellent defensive
possession of a half court at canter is
really hurting day but Pullum pulls up
and scores he ties it at 104 now stops
it with a shot bucket 7 it gets it back
McCullum's 3
[Applause]
he's 6-3 190 pounds and he's hit big
shot after big shot
feel the love CJ that's a beautiful shot
the ball Murray and the timer at five
Yogesh drives kicks it out
here's Murray and he got a three ties it
at 107
there's Millsap the veteran takes it in
on hood and scores that's the problem
right you take cancer out and now you've
got your two bigs Millsaps made a career
of scoring over guys and believe you're
contending with a double big lineup and
you've got smalls on the floor you have
to switch amino on to Jo pitch which
left hood on Paul Millsap nice and and
now the clock you end up with a turnover
Lillard misses a little finger roll
great job by Aminu to keep control and
CJ delivers yet again all seven here's
yolk it's with three yolk it's behind
the back for three in the wind we're
gonna double overtime
[Applause]
folks dragon on the floor right now
Lillard steps back this is good switches
at home to get the Blazers a two-point
lead got clock at 7 remember Cantor's
hobbling yoghurts goes Adam but can't
finish the tip won't go the first time
but will Barton with the second try ties
it at 111 Miller try to shake Harris
runs into yoke it shot clock down to 3
here's McCollum another teardrop not
that time got his own this puts it back
up
or the end of the fourth quarter had a
two-possession lead where the Blazers
get one here they work at around the
Lillard Bob's away from deep sea whether
he could make the NBA but driven
confident fearless delivery
[Applause]
Martin another three and will Barton has
been phenomenal here tonight that's a
huge triple lasers by two inside two to
play Millsap from yogurts were Thai the
smell set finishes good switch
defensively just that little bit of an
exchange by Murray and Millsap and it
leads to indecision and bucket but call
him thought Barton trying to save it
good night starting lineup and they
started to win he could have complained
he could have become a problem he's kept
playing and guess who's closing the game
shot clock down to six McCullum comes
and gets it with a timer for Barton on
him McCullum drives two on the shot
clock
poaching a minute to go of Denver
trailing by two they've been so
resilient all my Harris pins with the
left he finishes off the window were
even at 118 is on him Harris on Lillard
inbound to Lillard three seconds left
Lillard is it game time
triple overtime in Portland
each chance he gets being physical with
him 47 minutes played for Cantor here's
McCollum trying to shake yo gets buries
the jumper CJ McCollum a 36 you're
getting the switch so here comes the
screen by Kanter you've got to make the
switch because Kanter does a good job
holding up that guy and go ahead exhaust
it
you're not fleet of foot and keep up
terrorist reigns of three and Denver
takes a one-point lead
[Music]
Lillard goes to his left and that may
have been blocked from behind by Barton
loose ball
Aminu tied up with Barton it's a shot
clock violation though it was still
Portland possessions happening but
that's a sloppy pass the column step
back over Barton it's gone again CJ
McCollum
they double Lillard to force him to give
it up here's McCollum again
mismatched on the box as we're going to
show you McCallum first this is off of
the defensive play to 14 assists 17
rebounds 30 points gets it back with the
timer a day backing down an injured
cancer and finally yogic scores here in
overtime Denver back within two buries
finds Millsap timer at four Millsaps
spins over heartless Wow just this took
a long time for Murray to get the ball
right here but how about that shot by
Paul Millsap makalah's played 55 minutes
Lilith's plate 52 he gets by craig takes
it to the rim and gets the layup
so they score within 4 seconds to make
it a two-point game there's a
three-second difference between the game
and shot clock Horry chards was shutting
down Lillard here in the clutch now the
switch Craig gets him back here's
Lillard driving
Denver players he's sitting there going
I'm going to be close enough to contest
and Craig gets beat looks like he might
get a piece from behind here comes Hill
kids with a screen three seconds to go
pants are on Murray now with two with
one Mary for the win four overtimes for
the first time of the NBA Playoffs since
1953 but heartless playing 42 minutes we
weren't even sure he was going to play
tonight because of his injury Martin so
good in the second half and overtime
he's got 19 since intermission you can
usually see him get by Martin long - is
there nice cross nice cross to get a
feed looks fresh mr. Barton shot clock
at 8 Millsap goes to the left hand and
it rolls in what a shot by Millsap
to give Denver a one-point lead the
Cullen driving over to Nuggets off the
heels got it back to hood he'll try a
flea lasers
at three blocks the last game look at
him
this isn't somebody who's dunking in the
corner this is I'm out here at three I'm
rolling slide bottom the defender you
don't show discipline I put it down the
acquisitions by Niall O'Shea and Terry
Stotts